[Musik]
herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren über viertel nach acht dem talk
der schlagzeilen macht ich kann ihnen
gar nicht beschreiben wie sehr ich
vermisst habe in letzten wochen diesen
satz zu sagen und heute wird es wieder
sehr lebendig da bin ich mir sicher denn
ich habe tolle gäste zum einen heute
abend hier mit dabei cdu-vize carsten
rinne chefredakteur von media player
michael broeker politik chef jan schäfer
und eine frau die schon so viel in ihrem
leben gemacht hat da sich jetzt mehrere
berufsbezeichnung aufziehen muss die
schauspielerin ehemalige glücksfee
werden sie kennen dschungelkönigin und
wäre gerade fast bürgermeisterin
geworden waren gilt da und mein name ist
lena schickt das konzept der sendung ich
hoffe sie haben sich das erste mal
eingeschaltet ist sehr einfach jeder von
uns dann ein thema mitgebracht was ihn
bewegt schockiert oder das kennen sie
wahrscheinlich auch zu hause was mit
einfach mal mit anderen menschen
diskutieren dafür hat jeder zehn minuten
zeit dann folgt das zweite team auch
mich hat etwas bewegt das ist die korona
pandemie die sich seit wochen bewegt
aber diesmal ist es eine sache im
bundestag und zwar wurde ja für mich
ehrlich gesagt als bürgerin einfach mal
so der genesenen status für uns bürger
von sechs monaten auf drei monate
herabgesetzt
im bundestag darf man jetzt aber auch
weiterhin teilnehmen denn dort geht es
noch bis sechs monate da frage ich mich
okay was ist da eigentlich los geht
gelten für politiker andere regeln als
für die bürger für mich hat es etwas von
beim predigen und wasser trinken
also das kann ich nur bestätigen aber
gerade was die gerechtigkeit in dem fall
angeht gibt es doch sehr viel lobbyismus
also warum dürfen kinder nicht in die
schule gehen aber fußballspiele sind
alle haupt- und
das ist eine von vielen dingen die jetzt
wieder passiert sind wo man eben sagt
naja vielleicht fällt ja niemanden auf
aber als journalist sitzt man natürlich
dichter dran und kriegt einige sachen
ganz anders mitte und ich finde es gut
das ist hier mal zur sprache kommt ja
selbst betroffen bin frauchen ist es
eine sache die gar nicht geht das ist
genau die politikverdrossenheit die alle
mit mängeln ich meine man muss sagen es
wird ja eigentlich alles reguliert und
sehr schnell im bundestag wir müssen
selbst dem café aufschreiben wenn sie
selbst auf toilette gehen in den
deutschen bundestag steht da ein schild
jetzt zu
der aufenthalt muss kurz sein ja und das
ist nicht alles schnell reguliert also
wenn der toilettengang schnell reguliert
hält dann sollte man auch dieses schnell
regulieren ich finde das muss man von
jedem erwarten können deswegen haben wir
auch heute interveniert das möglichst
schnell hier wirklich gleiche regeln für
gleiche gelten ich bin genauso ein
bürger wie der bürger auf der straße und
das muss auch geld wie kann das denn
eigentlich passieren also wie wie kommt
so etwas zustande dass nicht nur das rkw
holterdiepolter in den genesenen status
einfach einfach mal halbiert über nacht
und wie kann so etwas passieren dass das
durch den bundestag geht macht das die
bundestagspräsidentin im alleingang oder
ist ja der ältestenrat involviert und
hat beide augen zugedrückt wie passiert
so was das ist der verwaltungsapparat
das ist nicht flexibel
ich will nicht sagen ich lösche das
sofort nur wenn ich diese mails bekomme
neue regeln im bundestag das ist so ne
lange latte dann ist da ein grosser
anderen habe ich schon kein bock mehr
darauf und das zeigt die die die völlige
fehlende flexibilisierung flexibilität
im verwaltungsapparat es geht ja runter
bis zur kommune der staat muss
eigentlich dienstleister seien für die
bürger und nicht staat in dem sinne wir
sind der staat und ihr seid da und wir
haben auf jeden fall bald ein echtes
akzeptanzproblem nicht nur in der
pandemie bewältigung passieren fehler
sondern eben auch in der frage was gilt
für uns und was gilt für andere ist es
für mich ein rätsel ich glaube bärbel
bas wird das sehr schnell passieren wird
in den nächsten tagen schon egal ob die
union da jetzt interveniert hat oder
oder nicht die bürger sind ja immer noch
gefrustet dass sie plötzlich nicht mehr
vollständig geimpft sind obwohl sie zwei
mal geimpft sind manche warten auch den
booster termin weil sie ihn noch nicht
haben dürfen und wir sind nicht gelten
dann plötzlich nicht mehr als geimpfte
es ist wahnsinn was an irrungen und
wirrungen gerade in der korona politik
los sind und diese einzig wichtige
politische kriterien das war eigentlich
immer hat nachvollziehbarkeit von
maßnahmen wird gerade eigentlich durch
die decke geschossen also es ist traurig
aber da würde mich natürlich auch
interessieren wenn im gebucht werden
muss weil die impfung nicht mehr so
lange vorhält wie ist es denn dann mit
den genesenden hält es wirklich nicht so
lange vor es ist deswegen sinnvoll die
zeit zu verkürzen
und wie sieht es dann aber auch wirklich
die nachfolge man bucht sein urlaub man
man muss arbeiten gehen wie sieht es aus
mit den arbeitgebern wie sind
was hat es alles für folgen für die
bevölkerung und das muss man natürlich
abwägen oder die frage stelle ich mir
natürlich auch es gibt die stadt in
süddeutschland ds konstanz und ist
direkt an der schweizer grenze danach
gibt es eine stadt die eis kreuzlingen
es sind 500 meter dann sind sie in
beiden städten in der einen stadt ist
der genesenen status zwölf monate und in
der anderen stadt drei monate ich bin
leider aber irgendwie kann man kann der
wissenschaft die frage stellen die man
auf so etwas kommt ich glaube wir werden
druck aber haben sie sich einen mann und
frau gilt sie ja auch sind ja auch ein
politischer mensch der termin ist auch
jetzt echt an ämtern geschnuppert hat
das eigentlich es so etwas gibt wie den
hang der volksvertreter gerne bis ins
kleinste detail dinge zu regeln für den
bürger also sich auch seine legitimation
da rauszuholen so dass mahlzeit dieses
mikromanagement eigentlich beschreiben
das was da passiert dass man versucht
sogar und das haben wir alles erlebt die
anzahl von kindern die zu einem
kindergeburtstag kommen dürfen dann
festzulegen also in drin nur noch acht
oder nur noch zehn das gab es letztes
jahr alles diese regelung also wie
kommen volksvertreter und dann können
sie vielleicht weil er auch was zu sagen
auf die idee dinge wirklich bis ins menü
nachher noch die schuhe größte was
journalisten an schulen tragen dürfen zu
regeln oder kommt dann wenn man angst
hat risiko zu gehen und dann regelt man
alles im detail damit man bloß nicht
schuldig ist im nachhinein es hat keiner
mehr den mut zu sagen das ist jetzt der
weg das ist jetzt die richtung und wir
machen das jetzt so und ich nehme auch
die verantwortung dafür das ist leider
deutschland der wohlstand hat und satt
gemacht ich glaube medizinisch gibt es
ja durchaus gute gründe denn wenn karl
lauterbach und so verstehe ich ihnen
sagt ja pass auf wenn der schutz den
impfschutz nach 23 monaten auf null
sinkt auf 10 prozent auf sonder mussten
die politik verändern das problem ist
die kommunikation ja da kommt ein lkw
gutachten über nacht in den bundesrat
hinein die länderchefs wissen gar nicht
bescheid die müssen dass er habe noch
mit muslimen gezeigt wie auch im
bundestag ja ich mir sowas kann noch
nicht passiert wenn selbst die
länderchefs die das umsetzen müssen
nicht bescheid wissen was das el kaida
macht frage ich mich wie kann karl
lauterbach diese behörde und die länder
haben ja so ist es zumindest unser
wissensstand die länderchefs haben ja
die zusage von karl lauterbach bekommen
dass er sich wohl auch ein bisschen also
stimmt jetzt mal mit ja und dann könnt
ihr aber noch auch ein bisschen noch
daran rumschrauben und noch mal sagen
was euch eigentlich bedrückt bei der
ganzen geschichte und wahrheit extrem
empörten überrascht dass weniger schon
später diese ganze genesungs verkürzung
oder halbierung muss man sagen dann
schon quasi ja verorteten status hatte
er hat er anerkennung als staat machen
aber nicht als politiker oder politikern
der pandemie das ist echt das problem
und wenn wir nicht bald aus dieser
pandemie irgendwie raus kommen wird
dieser schaden indem diese
politikverdrossen wird aufgrund dieser
aktuellen politik natürlich mit sich
bringt da wird immens sein und der wird
langfristig seien insofern ist es für
sie allen und egal welche partei am ende
ein ernsthaftes problem ja es ist
einfach so dass man zwar den den
menschen sagen will ja wir sind liberal
zum beispiel wir fdp und die die
menschen sollen selber entscheiden aber
letztendlich ist doch die gesundheit und
das leben und die sicherheit der
menschen dann doch wichtiger
und dann muss man auch wenn es ein nicht
gefällt dann manchmal doch sagen okay
wir machen das jetzt so die
anschnallpflicht und rauchverbot und es
gibt ja einiges wo die menschen zu etwas
gezwungen wurden aber trotzdem sollte
man die bürger mit einbeziehen und sie
richtig informieren und ich habe ganz
auf den eindruck dass die politiker sich
wie schafhirten fühlen die alles nur
gute wollen für ihre scharfe und die
auch meint sich in allem wunderbar und
am besten aus zugang aber die menschen
sind nun mal keine noch so ein bisschen
ahnung von volksvertretern zu volks
bestimmen oder nahrung und das ist
richtig wenn man sich an denen arkona
gipfel von gestern noch mal so ein
bisschen zurück erinnert ich weiß nicht
inwieweit michael brücker sicherlich
nina schick ja auch die beide
wahrscheinlich auch dieses papier die
siebenseitige das beschlusspapier
nachher durchgelesen hat was für
banalitäten muss man sagen in diesem
papier standen erschreckende banalitäten
also dann hätte man sich auch gar nicht
treffen müssen wir daran steht wir
wollen über eine öffnung perspektive
beraten wenn es dann so weit ist oder
ein gesundheitsminister wird
aufgefordert dafür zu sorgen bei einem
pcr-test mangel diesen mangel zu beheben
da regiert
und die sache jetzt ironisieren das ist
gar nicht fair aber sie als
stellvertreter sozusagen von vielen
anderen auch der kurs micro nicht so gut
macht ihr haar genau schreibt bereits
vor was passiert und wenn es dann dazu
kommt beispielsweise mal zu sagen wie
geht's eigentlich jetzt weiter wer kann
als erstes öffnen dann sagt man wir das
entscheiden wir wenn es so weit ist man
hier nicht sagen die frage richtig auch
sehr gerne an helene mann ich habe
letztens aus fdp kreisen gehört ohne uns
hätte es die lok downs wieder gegeben
weil die cdu wenn sie an die macht
gekommen wäre hätte sowieso geschlossen
dementsprechend hätte man wäre es denn
mit ihnen jetzt weiter gewesen
weitergelaufen waisenjungen jetzt sagt
sie sage ich natürlich jetzt hätte keine
chance gegeben hat ist dieses hin- und
hergeschiebe das wollen die leute da nie
mehr hören ich glaube entscheidend ist
was herr schäfer sagt warum steht dass
da alles so verklausuliert usw weil sich
jeder versteckt hinter paragrafen wir
brauchen eigentlich mal wieder mutbürger
es gab für mich zwei drei mutbürger in
dieser pandemie der eine war zum
beispiel der bürgermeister madsen aus
rostock alle haben gesagt im lockdown
wir machen hier nichts er wurde
angerufen von einzelhändlern und dann
hat er dieses click and meet erfunden
weil bürger gesagt hat lasst mich doch
da anrufen dann hole ich die schuhe ab
oder die tasche oder die flasche wein
und dann machen wir das so und halten
zumindest den einzelhandel so ein
bisschen noch am leben alle haben sich
versteckt dann lief es hat ganz
deutschland nach gemacht das wäre mein
vorschlag 30 modellregionen in
deutschland für mutbürger diejenigen die
was ausprobieren wollen dürfen das
machen und wenn es läuft jetzt
ausgerollt in ganz deutschland das wäre
eine tolle sache gewesen aber wir hatten
natürlich auch ein bisschen pech dass
gerade als die panini losging war mitten
im wahlkampf und keiner wollte in fehler
machen sondern wollte gewählt werden und
dann ja dann war zwar gewählt aber in
der übergangsphase wo alle mit
koalitionsgesprächen beschäftigt waren
aber die cdu immer noch an der macht da
wollte dann auch keiner was tun und auch
die cdu hat sich da zurück gehalten und
das waren aber entscheidende phasen
gewesen wo man vielleicht etwas hätte
beschließen und machen sollen ein hut
bürgermeister will ich noch erwähnen den
aus bremen ich finde nämlich der hat
damals die impfzentren nicht geschlossen
als wir sagen wir mal im spätsommer der
meinung waren wir brauchen den ich mir
auch politiker der union auch der
gesundheitsminister an sparen und er hat
gesagt ich muss die impfzentren haben
weil wir brauchen niedrigschwellige
angebote für impfungen in den vierteln
wo die menschen nun nicht mal mehr ein
hausarzt haben da müssen wir rein da
sind heute übrigens jetzt auch die
probleme da haben wir die impflücken da
hat er sie offen gehalten deswegen ist
die impf wurde da heute auch so hoch wie
sie ist also es gibt auch gute beispiele
dafür nicht ganz klar mehr mut
bürgermeister ich finde es ist eine ganz
tolle forderung oder eine schnelle weg
zur beendigung meines themas wir
brauchen mehr mut bürger in diesem land
das finde ich auch und wir bleiben weil
der korona pandemie weil dich jahren hat
auch etwas beschäftigt was damit sehr
eng zusammenhängend ja mich beschäftigt
eigentlich dass wir uns seit zwei jahren
mit der korona faust begrüßen einige
hatten ja sogar den corona ellbogen dann
in den haben sich sage größten ziemlich
okay
also die begrüßungsrituale sozusagen
bekannten eigentlich gar kein limit hier
sehen wir das auch noch mal und ich muss
sagen diese krone faust ii geht
zunehmend auf die nerven ich fordere den
handschlag zurück der anschlag der steht
für ehrlichkeit der steht für
zuverlässigkeit wissen dass der anschlag
vor gericht sogar auch als justiziabel
gilt wer einen deal ab schließt per
handschlag und die fakten geklärten auf
beiden seiten der kann sich dann auch am
ende darauf verlassen so was zumindest
früher und das war früher alles gar
nicht so schlecht deswegen fordere ich
auch als hoffnungsschimmer der hand lag
wusste zurück und ich würde ganz gerne
eigentlich in dieser runde anfange mit
dem
jetzt auch nigeria im verkehr wichtig
aus kontakten verlags ja ich bin auch
sehr dafür dass der anschlag zurückkehrt
ist würde ich jetzt wahrscheinlich
verwundern aber ich fand ja ganz
lächerlich den ellbogen weil damit kann
man sicher näher als mancher der hand
gekommen wäre und auch mit der faust
berührt man übrigens ja auch irgendwo
sich ich find auch der hand schlagen wo
es zurückkehren es wäre auch wieder ein
zeichen der normalität und die
handhygiene hat ja auch eigentlich jeder
selber drauf wissen ja wie sieht dieses
video betrieb des rk ii sagt selbst
haupt übertragung durch die luft er ja
und wenn dann gibt es auch auf
metallenen flächen rückstände aber
eigentlich so gut wie gar nicht hier an
der hand und ob ich nun so mache oder ob
ich so mache und mir danach
beispielsweise die hände wasche also das
wasser einweichen und verschwindet wenn
man der politik gelegen die
symbolpolitik formel würde ich sagen ist
das auch eine symbol forderung aber ich
meine am ende hast du natürlich recht
wir haben jahrzehnte lang aerosol
forschung inzwischen betrieben so kommt
einem das vor und wir wissen dass es
dann doch vielleicht nicht die
tröpfcheninfektion ist diese überträgt
also von mir auch sehr gerne vielleicht
wäre es ein schönes symbol um da wieder
rauszukommen entscheidend wird es nicht
sein aber es gibt hoffnung ich das mal
sagen darf also diese wenn man sagt der
wunsch zurück zu kommen zu einem leben
in freiheit und er riecht und schließt
an das was wir vorher auch erlebt haben
dann ist doch herr lehmann wenn ich
ihnen jetzt die hand hier so gebe einen
tisch das heißt doch wertschätzung auch
in den reaktoren bringen werden ja nicht
nur el sol forschung gemacht
jahrzehntelang sondern auch handschlag
forscher jahrhundert sehen bei den
jahrhundertelangen bei allen epidemien
bei cholera bei gelbsucht bei der
spanischen grippe überall ist danach der
anschlag zurück gekommen selbst unsere
engsten verwandten oder nächsten
verwandten der schimpanse sie schimpfen
sie begrüßen sich veranschlagt also um
den handschlag machen ich mir keine
sorgen nicht zwischen dem sonnen und
markus söder aber generell wird er
zurückgezogen trotzdem ist das jetzt für
mich nicht kein thema ich wäre er dafür
dass wir darüber reden dass wir eben
einzelhandel wieder zweig haben sollen
dass das abgeschafft wird dass das nicht
noch ist also in bayern ist es
abgeschafft im saarland die gerichte
abgeschafft nicht die politik sie alle
schätzen die symbol für dich erst einmal
sagen darf also wenn sie können frei sie
können sagen für mich kein thema ich
halte das für ein entscheidendes thema
es gibt diese tollen fotos der
bundeskanzlerin mit maske zweimal
geimpft damals noch zu einer geben stand
begrüßt sich trotzdem mit mit diesem
ellbogencheck mit frau von der leyen
beispielsweise das ist doch an
absurdität entschuldigung hast dass du
sagen so über vielleicht sollten wir ja
uns mal andere kulturen angucken denn
ich weiß noch wie ich es früher immer
belächelt haben und komisch an wenn ich
irgendwelche berichte aus china fand
oder auch wenn ich in asiatische länder
gereist bin dass viele menschen auf der
straße immer masken trugen und ich
wusste man gar nicht beim tragen die
dann immer masken und so haben sie so
eine angst sich irgendwie anzustecken
mit einmal tragen wir alle masken aber
auch gerade die asiaten die inder und
die thailänder die begrüßen sich so eben
weil sie nicht gerne wären übertragen
das sind eben auch alles länder wo es
mit der hygiene nicht so gut bestellt
ist und ich finde dass sie doch sehr
eleganter aus warum müssen wir uns mal
an tatschen also vielleicht wäre das ja
auch mal nicht
überholen ist und noch so
der wichtige punkt ist natürlich ist es
etwas etwas moore voll natürlich auch
wenn man darüber spricht aber ich glaube
auch dass es ein ganz ganz wichtiger
punkt zurückzukehren und wieder ins
normale leben zu kehren ich finde schon
sehr anstrengend dass man nie weiß wie
man sich gegen abend wieder einsetzte
ist mal ein zippel zapel anlagen der
anschlag hat die wertschätzung und ein
handschlag schaut man sich ja auch in
die augen bei der korona faust guckt
jeder hauptsache ich treffe
ich dass die wartezone
ist mir böse gestimmt also ich find der
handschlag der tritt vielmehr aus hellem
man ja ich bin ich bin kein videobeweis
nicht denn jetzt im bundestag wenn man
sich denn da so trifft im saal werde
sich dann aktuelle grünes frei
nein aber ich weiß nicht wie es wäre
logisch ist aber jetzt die viren
übertragung weil man ja schon mit der
handfläche die schleimhäute er berührt
ohne dass man es merkt augen nase mund
und da macht man es nicht bin kein
biologe aber das könnte wahrscheinlich
wird er ist wahrscheinlich der grund
gibt es dann irgendwo auf diesem globus
schon einen standort wo man sich wieder
die hände geht der schäfer also hier
beispielsweise wir haben es kann aber
auch jeder möchten wir wollen ja auch
keinen zu nahe treten das ist wieder der
punkt in der kommune ein panini man weiß
nie wie aber gibt's schon ort also ich
würde sagen dass beispielsweise in
amerika schon auch ein fehler der orden
wieder mehr freiheit einzug gehalten hat
und ich habe letztens mit dem schweizer
telefoniert er war sehr verwundert wie
viele unserer zeitung noch voll sind mit
dem corona themen also vielleicht war es
nur von ihnen ansichtssache aber ich
glaube wir haben schon mehr orte wo
wieder freiheit herrscht
absolut also ich bin auch ein großer fan
von hendrik strikt der optimistisch ist
und dieses auch ausstrahlt
weil ich meine dass wir jetzt nicht auf
das thema impfpflicht kommen so man
sieht ja auch in der bevölkerung wird
das jetzt anders gesehen das thema
empfiehlt wenn ich die aktuellen umfrage
fragen sehe wie vor ein paar monaten ich
war immer schon kritisch und wenn alle
jetzt sagen ja und micr on lernen sie
auch dafür gegen die impfpflicht aus
absolut und und vielleicht
machen wir da nur ein vorratsbeschluss
und das spüren die menschen die wollen
doch raus ja und wenn man jetzt wieder
neue maßnahmen diskutiert und hinterher
wieder eine große enttäuschung ist weil
die pandemie immer noch da ist ja dann
ist auch nichts gewollten dann kommt
wieder die politikverdrossenheit und das
wird immer mehr und deswegen müssen wir
jetzt wirklich raus nach vorne spielen
wird es noch dauern gelände meine frau
weiß ich nicht ich höre halt zu wenn er
strebt beispielsweise sagt dass jetzt
die die viruslast zu sagen sagt iris
kampf ja zurückgeht etwas mehr ja auch
die auswirkung dass die dass die folgen
bilder sind ja auch die nebenwirkungen
etc dass das dann zu einer emmy werden
kann macht mir das hoffnung müsse die
frage stellen wie lange dauert es noch
unter einem kanzler scholz und wie lange
würde es beim kanzler märz dauern
bei herrn scholz ist ja mal ganz
interessant
man muss ja ich dreimal erstmal zuhören
was er überhaupt meint also ich hab ihn
letztens live gesehen im deutschen
bundestag durchsetzen frage also die hat
eine unglaubliche
eigenschaft dinge dann immer auf
flughöhe zu beantworten also selbst wenn
man eben diese frage stellen würde hätte
man vermutlich danach keine antwort
friedrich merz der ist jetzt richtig zug
drin wir haben am wochenende unserem
parteitag gehabt haben wir erste
bundesvorstandssitzung hat die dauerte
30 minuten da war richtig zug drin wir
haben jetzt alle bock in der gt
ja das tut uns doch auch mal gut oder
würde es ihnen nicht auch tut das nicht
mal diese stunde gut dass wir unser
handy einfach mal mit liegen haben ich
fand sie trotzdem wollen wichtig dass
dann nach den vorstand so auch wieder
ein paar informationen raus gekommen und
man kann ja auch menschen danach anrufen
also ganz zu verlieren braucht das nicht
die erste bundesvorstandssitzung aber
ich glaube das ist auch unfair wir
wissen es schlicht ich wir wissen es
schlicht nicht wie lange sie dauert man
kann das weder von olaf scholz noch von
friedrich merz erfragen was ich erwartet
ist im dritten jahr der pandemie dass
wenn wir jetzt wieder niedrige zahlen
kommen und das wird ja im märz april
nach lage der virologen so kommen dass
wir dann vorbereitungen haben dass wir
einfach dieses mal ausnahmsweise
vorbereitungen für den herbst für den
winter falls eben doch eine neue
variante kommt das erwarte ich von der
politik damit meine ich nicht die
allgemeine impfpflicht aber ich meine
sie an anderer stelle wir haben zwei mal
gnadenlos versagt und spätsommer
prävention scheint mehr teil der politik
zu sein und das müssen wir dieses jahr
anders machen und wie lange sie dauert
ist dass wir wegen es mal luft reinigen
filter bekommen für die schule wir haben
wir bis heute ja nicht die schulen
besser ausstatten und so damit die
kinder in die schule gehen können ohne
angst haben zu müssen dass wenn sie nach
hause kommen ihrer ganzen familie
anstecken und alles in quarantäne und
dann fahren keine busse weil die
busfahrer krank sind und und und also
habe ich meine daten keine echtzeitdaten
wir können gar nicht sagen wie ist die
intensiv belegungssituation gerade
wirklich wissen krömer
der charité chef hat bei der
bundesländer sitzung jetzt gerade
gefleht bitte organisiert mir an
digitalisiertes gesundheitswesen damit
wir echtzeitdaten haben und
entscheidungen treffen können und da war
dann schweigen in der runde das ist
einfach nur noch peinlich aber michael
du hast uns heute ja auch ein thema
mitgebracht wo man auch etwas besser
machen könnte ja so sehr wie sich jan
schäfer einen anschlag wieder wünscht
wünsche ich mir eine pragmatische
funktionierende und wirksame
energiepolitik ich glaube das wird der
lackmustest für die ampel koalition in
den nächsten monaten und jahren denn der
energiepreis stock ist spürbar und ich
habe keine ahnung wie robert habeck
masterplan für die energiewende dazu
führen könnte dass vielleicht gerade
auch sozial benachteiligte gruppen am
ende strom und heizung bezahlen können
was längst zu einer zweiten miete
geworden ist also hier brauchen wir
sofort ein entlastungs einer entlastung
offensive auf dem thema energiepreise
und hier ist die ampel gefordert sonst
haben wir irgendwann ein hartz4 für die
grünen und das bedeutet dann massenhafte
demonstrationen nicht gegen die korona
politik sondern gegen die energiepolitik
der bundesregierung
michael ich kann dich da nur
unterstützen in dem was du gesagt hast
ich glaube auch es geht einmal um die
frage wie energie bezahlbar bleiben kann
vollkommen richtig die zweite frage ist
glaube ich wie deutschland es überhaupt
verhindert in eine energie armut
abzurutschen also die große frage
ausstieg aus der kernkraft bis ende
dieses jahres dann ausstieg aus der
kohlekraft bis ende 2030 also innerhalb
von neun jahren und wenn wir jetzt
einmal nur mal anschauen wie viel strom
wir derzeit brauchen 530 terawatt schon
pro jahr irgendwie zahlen der 530 und
das soll ja steigen dieser
stromverbrauch auf bis zu 700 30
terawattstunden 2030 also von 530 auf
730 ungefähr so jetzt nehmen wir aber
ungefähr die hälfte dessen was erzeugt
würde mich aus kohle und kernkraft
daraus 530 durch zwei sondern so bei 270
82 sollen aber jetzt auf 730 kommt das
heißt wir müssen ja von neun jahren
eigentlich den anteil der erneuerbaren
nicht nur verdoppeln sondern fährt
zweimal so um 200 prozent
steigern und das ist doch eine
herausforderung weiß nicht sie aus der
politik kommt was sie dazu sagen aber
ich halte das für schier unmöglich das
zu machen deswegen glaube ich droht uns
mit der klimapolitik die die ampel plant
ein absolutes debakel in finanzieller
hinsicht für die bürgerinnen bürger für
die firmen aber dann auch mit der großen
frage haben wir eigentlich noch energie
und strom sicherheiten naja da streitet
sich natürlich die wirtschaftlichkeit
mit dem wie
verhindern wir jetzt das
dass der klimawandel noch voranschreitet
aber ich glaube einfach selbst wenn wir
alle kollektiven selbstmord begehen und
unsere tiere gleich mit tüten werden wir
werden wir daran nichts ändern denn dazu
mit unseren 0,2 prozent hier in
deutschland wird es nicht gehen und ob
wir jetzt wirklich die vorbildfunktion
geben wo dann die ganze welt drauf guckt
auch die machen das richtig und so wie
die deutschen so machen wir es auch das
glaube ich eher nicht wir sollten
wirklich auf forschung setzen ganz klar
und dass auch die behördenwege sich
verkürzen weil das ist jetzt einfach so
windkrafträder ja bis die mal genehmigt
werden da ist ja alles vorbei und die
bevölkerung will auch keine
windkrafträder aus den bekannten grund
sehnlich schön aus vogelflug und
schatten die sich da bilden aber
vielleicht gibt es andere technologien
vielleicht kann man wirklich unter
unseren agrarflächen erdwärme erzeugen
und vielleicht gibt es andere
möglichkeiten die schneller gehen und
natürlich auch thorium reaktoren es
kommt jetzt aus china und das ist ja
verteufelt und reaktoren das an alle
gleich auch um himmels willen bloß nicht
die wollen wir doch alle abschaffen aber
vielleicht wäre das ja eine gute
übergangslösung
die sollen jahr 2030
kommerzialisiert werden
auf den markt kommen vielleicht sollte
man die bevölkerung und auch die grünen
davon überzeugen dass ist als
übergangslösung bis dann wirklich die
erneuerbare energie funktioniert
vielleicht wäre das inzwischen lösung
das problem ist ja stichwort
versorgungssicherheit also die
energiewende ist schon eine riesen
chance für uns wenn ich allein an den
mittelstand denke von paar jahren jetzt
ist es ja nicht mehr durch corona aber
auf der hannover messe der sind hallen
voll mit deutscher umwelttechnologie die
wir weltweit exportieren wie autos wie
maschinen und so weiter eine
riesenchance das problem ist nur wir
müssen ehrlich bleiben wir dürfen keine
doppelmoral zeigen und dürfen auch nicht
doppelt ziemlich sein also es kann nicht
sein dass wir hier aus kernkraft gehen
aus kohle gehen jetzt gaskraftwerke
vilja wollen viele nicht haben und dann
importieren wir den strom aus atomkraft
aus frankreich und aus kohle aus kohle
aus tschechien das wäre doppelt ziemlich
das ist uns mal in der landwirtschaft
passiert hätte ich auch nicht richtig
wir hatten früher hier käfige
hühnerkäfigen die haben die hier
verboten und jetzt kommen die eier die
wir essen die frühstückseier die
comdirect deutschland aber alle eier die
veredelt sind zb den nudeln et cetera ja
kommen jetzt vor allem aus osteuropa wo
noch viel niedrigere tierschutzstandards
sind als bei uns aber wir sagen kommt
doch jetzt nicht aus deutschland also
uns geht es sehr gut das ist doppelt
wenn ich das eine doppelmoral und da
erwarte ich von der politik auch von
meiner partei dass man hier den rücken
gerade macht dass man ehrlich ist weil
die leute sind nicht blöd die
durchschauen das ja und deswegen
wirklich vorsicht an der bahnsteigkante
das ist auch zum teil
schaufensterpolitik was wir da betreiben
auch bei der braunkohle da hat man ja
gesagt 238 geht es raus die braunkohle
ist bereits in einem markt system drin
wo man ein preis bezahlen muss für die
umweltverschmutzung was richtig ist und
je teurer der preis desto mehr druck hat
man um in andere technologien zu gehen
das fall findet jetzt statt das heißt
selbst wenn die politik keinen beschluss
gefasst hätte wir müssen schon 20 30 aus
wäre es 20 34 35 33 wir sind also ich
will sagen die menschen sind nicht blöd
ja die haben sehr viel ahnung auch über
die energiewende die wollen die
energiewende aber mit den menschen nicht
gegen die menschen und auch ehrlich sein
und nicht hinterher die atomkraft
hierzulande
zahlen mitgebracht michael ist ja nicht
nur sehr gerne und sehr aufmerksam deren
hauptstadt brief in seinem editorial ja
noch ganz viele andere spannende
medienprodukt und einen zeit fand ich
sehr spannend und zwar habt ihr nämlich
mal euch gefragt wie viel ist ein
deutscher bereit für das klima aussehen
und 62 prozent sagen weniger als 50 euro
pro monat da habe ich schon geschluckt
und mir gedacht okay ich bin ja auch
total ehrlich gesagt bei ihnen herr
lehne man hier darf man ja auch als
moderatorin seine meinung sagen ich
finde vielerlei von der energiewende was
wir plan völlig skurril aber schaffen
wir es vielleicht einfach nicht anders
diese zahlen schon zum nachdenken damals
gemacht 2 und 2 62 prozent der deutschen
sagen sie würden weniger als 50 euro pro
monat für den klimawandel für den
klimaschutz ausgeben die politik die
frage und das haben sie ihr glaube ich
auch gerade gesagt frau gilt ist ja was
schaffen wir eigentlich was bringen wir
der welt wenn man klimaschutz als auch
multinationales projekt ja sieht das
schaffen wir eigentlich mit einem euro
den wir hier noch in klimaschutz stecken
wie viele reduzieren wir eigentlich den
co2 ausstoß beispielsweise oder könnte
dieser euro selbst wenn er aus
deutschland kommt also von deutschen
steuerzahlern möglicherweise anderen
ländern einen viel größeren effekt
erzeugen da gibt es ja untersuchen die
ganz klar sagen dass einsparen einer
tonne co2 sind deutschland mittlerweile
fast zehnmal so teuer wie beispielsweise
das einsparen einer tonne co2 in afrika
oder auf dem asiatischen kontinent das
bedeutet ich könnte mit einem aus
deutschland kommen den investierten euro
ich will gar nicht mehr sagen dass sie
anders dann bezahlen müssen man könnte
ja sagen aus deutschland kommen mit dem
ein euro viel mehr erreichen wenn ich
ihn gerne hier investiere in klimaschutz
sondern woanders und das heißt wir
könnten also beim faktor zehn mit zehn
euro die wir von hier woanders
investieren das gleiche erreichen zehn
euro muss man sich ja vorstellen ja nun
können wir natürlich erst unsere politik
für für uns in deutschland machen ich
weiß was du meinst du kann er ja in den
anderen ländern entscheiden was sie mit
unserem investierten euro ausmachen da
nur du musst es hier schaffe und ich
verstehe durchaus das ansinnen zu sagen
lasst uns vorreiter sein das ist nicht
ganz schlecht bei technologieoffenheit
bei einem möglichen neuen
geschäftsmodell für deutschland ich
hätte nur gerne in einem land geht einem
nachbarort
da geht interessiert am ende doch was in
deutschland passiert das weltklima aber
ich kann es ja auch wenig an die
technologie nur exportieren und dann
werden die besten gaskraftwerke oder die
schönsten wasserstoffanlagen irgendwie
im ausland gebaut ich war ja nicht ich
will die werden die ja hier haben sie
absolut nicht will sie funktionieren
aber die reduktion der effekt den ich
habe der ist möglicherweise mit dem dort
investierten euro mag sein aber das mag
ist wahrscheinlich am ende die länder
dort vor ort ob sie den darüber müssen
sie ja auch importieren also zum
beispiel in afrika und in länder mit
vielen wüsten erscheint vielmehr sonne
und als bei uns in deutschland es gibt
es gibt auch länder in denen viel mehr
wind als bei uns in deutschland und wenn
wir also ökostrom aus dem ausland
importieren und nicht nur kohle und
kraft kernkraft energie vielleicht wäre
das auch die möglichkeit dass wir ihnen
unsere forschung und unsere
möglichkeiten verkaufen anbieten lernen
und dafür von ihnen den ökostrom krach
machen wir wir machen grüne wasserstoff
projekte mit nordafrika ich glaube diese
ganzen technologiepartnerschaft mit
einer ländern machen wir trotzdem ist
für mich der punkt den haben sie
angesprochen lindemann kriegen die grüne
ist in ihrer eigenen klientel durch dass
wir tatsächlich dieses land umbauen
werden und zwar sichtbar nicht nur wegen
der winterberger sondern auch wegen
verpflichtungen für eigentümer für
hauseigentümer was sich in halbwegs
masterplan lese ist enorm wenn ich sehe
dass der durchschnittliche bestandene
der gebäude in deutschland ungefähr 80
er jahre ist und die alle nicht
energetisch saniert sind aber sich ein
60 jähriges paar vielleicht gar nicht
leisten kann das energetisch zu sanieren
weil sie noch nicht mal 5000 euro dann
noch investieren wollen sie kriegen sie
können wir auch noch gar keine kredite
aber lassen wir einfach sagen er muss in
seiner eigenen klientel für die
akzeptanz sorgen und wir müssen schon
scharf das ist doch praktisch machen
aber weil wir sagen es muss klappen und
das sagen die grünen auch mal so
professor kämpfer hat jetzt nicht
verdächtigt dass sie besonders ihrer
partei nahesteht sondern eher den grünen
hat das ja mal ausgerechnet um das 20 30
alles zurecht was robert habeck plan
sagt sie alle viereinhalb stunden müsste
in deutschland ein neues windrad ans
netz gehen alle viereinhalb stunden
bedeutet wir müssen jetzt sofort
anfangen wir wissen aber selbst in baden
württemberg grün regiert seit vielen
vielen jahren hat sich die zeit bis 1
trat dann am ende gebaut werden kann
genehmigungsphase hat sich auf vier
jahre verkürzt vier jahre das heißt wenn
wir jetzt anfangen würden mit denen ganz
moderne ja auch ändern und zwar soll er
die ganzen gründe warum kein windrad
gebaut werden so minimiert werden und
dass er jetzt ganz schnell gehen das
muss mit dem landwirtschaftsminister und
tierschutz minister ihr müsst du mir
besprechen der eigentlich den greifvogel
und die kröte natürlich bewahren soll
das hauptthema wird sein
technologieoffenheit bei der
energiewende und auch beschleunigung und
versus artenschutz und auch da bin ich
wieder dabei dann müssen sich die grünen
in ihren eigenen reihen erst mal ehrlich
machen und die versprechen sind mir auf
jeden fall ein bisschen zu ambitioniert
was da im plan steht also wenn man es im
plan schreibt dass die
genehmigungsverfahren halbiert werden
finde ich super ich glaube das würde
jeder unterstreichen aber wenn es dann
konkret wird dann tut sehr weh weil es
ja im eigenen garten ist jetzt mal
bildlich gesprochen ja also muss ja
nicht nur die die windkraft ist ein
beispiel oder
die bahninfrastruktur jeder ist für die
bahn der ausbau der bahnstrecke von
berlin nach münchen da fahre ich jetzt
vier stunden früher brauchte sechs
stunden hat 26 jahre gedauert das geld
war die ganze zeit da aber dann gab es
immer initiativen vor ort wegen dieser
sache nicht oder wegen jener sache wenn
wir 26 jahre für so eine blöde oder eine
gute bahn strecke nutzt sie auch
brauchen die sonne gegangen die
energiewende schaffen
jetzt haben wir köln/berlin dasselbe
thema da fahren wir sechs stunden mit
dem ic war und seit zehn jahren
diskutieren darüber dass wir einen haben
vielleicht nicht die die ics auseinander
koppeln sondern vielleicht eine
ersatzstrecke das ist ein wahnsinniges
genau ist nur die erwartungshaltung ist
groß wobei habeck verspricht viel und
die enttäuschung kann sehr großen und
der widerstand im volk der punkt ist
glaube ich und den sehen wir in unserer
runde auch wir haben irgendwie nicht den
doppelten boden was machen wir
eigentlich wenn es nicht klappt ja über
diese um diese frage drückt sich
eigentlich jeder herum es wird ja und
heute als rassismus klappt ist ratlos
und januar stehe ich es muss klar sein
input aber was ist von januar an jeder
die gleiche doppelt ziemlich kalt so
kann bei den käfigen auch aber dass das
dass er ihnen ehrlich aber mal ganz
einfacher vorschlag wirklich ganz
einfach warum ist der sprit teurer
geworden es gibt tausend gründe aber ein
grund ist man muss einen co2 preis sei
eine co2 abgabe und dann gibt es
milliarden die werden jedes jahr
angesammelt und diese milliarden sollte
man eins zu eins an die verbraucher
zurückgeben weil der er die idee ist ja
ich mache teurer damit die firmen
innovativer werden damit ich mir
überlege damit der bürgermeister mit
rucksack vielleicht pnv auszubauen und
so weiter aber das geld gehört doch den
menschen das muss eins zu eins zurück
stattdessen wird jetzt ein teil wieder
quersubventioniert in irgendwelche
anderen dinge das wäre meine forderung
finde ich dies einfach und es käme
zurück den gleichen fehler jungs bei der
rente gemacht da sind auch
versicherungsfremde leistungen die gar
nichts mit der rente zu tun mit den
beiträgen ja über die beiträge bezahlt
worden und die ihnen die beiträge
bezahlt haben haben dann hinterher
weniger rente bekommen viel zu
kompliziert ich würde noch ich würde sie
sind journalist sie können nein aber ich
würde einfach an die steuern abgaben
rangehen 40 prozent der roman sind
steuern und abgaben das kann die politik
selbst entscheiden wie sie den
strompreis reguliert trotz der ganzen
internationalen verwerfungen die es auch
bei den gaspreisen gibt verstehen also
warum steuer und fordern schaffen sofort
werden auf analyse der probleme am ende
nein aber es ist ja dass ich
gleichzeitig haben die machbar das jetzt
machen musst du jetzt machen trotzdem
die anderen dinge machen das ist so eine
würden ich muss leider wir würden wir
werden das thema heute jetzt nicht mehr
am tisch beenden wir sind gleich wieder
zurück auch ich muss sagen nach der
langen winterpause habe ich eigentlich
keine pause notwendig aber wir müssen
eine machen gleich sind wir wieder da
[Musik]
so wir sind wieder zurück hierbei fälle
nach dem tod der schlagzeilen macht
meine gäste heute abend cdu vorsitzender
carsten linnemann chefredaktor familie
pionier michael brück politik chef jan
schäfer und maren gilzer schauspielerin
und mein name ist der schinken und wir
machen jetzt direkt weiter und zwar
kommen wir jetzt zu der kassen linnemann
und seinem thema ich war gestern im
führt den ganzen tag wir haben gefeiert
ludwig erhard ist 125 jahre alt geworden
würde er noch leben er ist der vater der
sozialen marktwirtschaft der vater hat
deutschlands wirtschaftswunder er hat
damals die spielregeln geschaffen mit
denen deutschland dann am ende des tages
ja so erfolgreich wurde und diese
spielregeln werden heute mit füßen
getreten aktuelles beispiel jetzt am
donnerstag in dieser woche im plenum
wird der jahreswirtschaftsbericht
besprochen und diskutiert von herrn
haare herr habe ich möchte der eine
soziale marktwirtschaft um modellieren
sie sollen in zukunft nicht mehr soziale
marktwirtschaft sondern soziale
ökologische marktwirtschaft heißen
ludwig erhard würde sich im grab
umdrehen weil er sagen würde die soziale
marktwirtschaft wenn man sich richtig
anwendet ist im sich ökologisch weil
wenn man die umwelt verschmutzt muss man
auch geld dafür bezahlen das ist das
sogenannte haftungsprinzip und ich mache
mir sorgen um diese soziale
marktwirtschaft weil mittlerweile immer
mehr parteien sich die soziale
marktwirtschaft zu eigen machen für
opportune zwecke selbst sahra
wagenknecht ist vor einigen jahren durch
deutschland gerannt und hat einen
vortrag gehalten unter dem titel
rückbesinnung auf nützlich ehrt das
macht mir sorgen das möchte ich
kann verstehen ist carsten linnemann sie
sorgen macht wenn sarah wagenknecht
nicht recht geht aber ich finde man
erstmal robert habeck zu verteidigen
eine ökologisch soziale marktwirtschaft
ist an sich kein schlechter gedanke ich
will nur mal darauf hinweisen dass die
wirtschaft ja selber drängt die
wirtschaft will co2 frei werden die
wirtschaft will nachhaltiger werden weil
sie das als geschäftsmodell sieht für
die zukunft mir macht er die politik
sorgen dass sie fast nicht mehr versteht
was ordnungspolitik früher einmal war
nämlich anreize zu schaffen anstatt
vorgaben zu machen planungen zu machen
anreize zu schaffen und dann eben
vielleicht die marktkräfte sich
entwickeln zu lassen das ist kreditiert
worden und muss politik muss man sagen
von fast allen parteien das macht mir
sorgen aber eine ökologisch nachhaltige
volkswirtschaft als geschäftsmodell
deutschland wir brauchen ein neues
geschäftsmodell da sind wir uns alle
einig dass industrie wunder kommt nicht
mehr also jan uns nicht wir werden
diesen euro entlastet mich den das
argument man mit kohle und
gaskraftwerken und dem mittelstand der
nachkriegsjahre werden wir
selbstverständlich nicht die
weltwirtschaft beeindrucken können wir
können das mit technologie mit
technologieoffenheit und sicherlich auch
mit nachhaltigen technologien aber dann
müssen wir da die richtigen akzente
setzt und damals mir bei der politik
sorgen aber nur des geschäfts 100 wird
deutschland brauchen definitiv also wir
befinden uns ja hier in einer krassen
film hat gesagt sozialen marktwirtschaft
und in einer marktwirtschaft ist es ganz
generell eigentlich so dass die firmen
selbst sehen selbst entdecken die
unternehmer die mitarbeiter selbst
entdecken wo gibt es eine neue trends wo
passiert das so passiert das wo muss ich
investieren darf der staat eigentlich
gar nicht vorgeben und wir wenn
unternehmer sagen haben ein interesse
daran
uns nachhaltig aufzustellen dann ist es
auch jedem unternehmer freigestellt das
zu machen es hat niemand ihren mast
gezwungen ein auto herzustellen was
quasi mit batterie betrieben wird und
nicht mit diesel oder benzin wird hat
keiner gemacht hat ihren mast
selbstständig gemacht auch übrigens ddr
wurde ja unterlassungen jetzt ein
computersystem ist schnell hat er selbst
gemacht oder
barcelona sie werden dort wäre in
deutschland gescheitert elon musk wer an
tag eins gescheitert mit allen auflagen
die hätte erfüllen um an tag eins dieses
unternehmen sind das nein der politik
muss planungssicherheit liefern und sie
muss eine ordnungspolitische struktur
liefern sich überhaupt gründen kann wie
lange das ist ein anderes problem ist
aber dass es darum nicht schwer aber da
geht es darum wird innovation verhindert
als und planung so wäre wenn es das
haben die unternehmen aber aber zu sagen
ich mach jetzt eine ökologische
mannschaft werden dass grünen
parteiprogramme rein schaut der sieht ja
was damit gemeint ist damit ist
staatliche bevormundung gehabt um es
ganz plastisch zu machen etwas
überspitzt jetzt der bäcker der
ökologische brötchen backt er hat quasi
anrecht auf eine subvention der der sie
nicht packt hat kein anrecht auf eine
subvention da beginnt das problem wenn
man einen co2 preis vorgibt wofür ich
total bin dann ist das in co2 preis und
dann kann sich am ende der bäcker selbst
aussuchen ob er mit dem alten diesel
generator seine brötchen backt oder ob
er das mit solarstrom macht
beispielsweise das wenn man sagt
hochwertiger weise sind um diese strom
natürlich nicht machen deswegen der co2
lenkungswirkung ist eine politische
lenkungswirkung nur ein effizientes
instrument da wäre ich sofort für und
zwar dann aber bitte nicht
deutschlandweit sondern global oder
zumindest europäischen co2
zertifikatehandel für alle branchen das
hätte die grosse koalition mal
durchsetzen können in europa hat sie
leider nicht gemacht es gibt sie nur für
zwei branchen- insofern ich bin für
marktwirtschaftliche instrumente sie
können aber trotzdem im ziel eine
ökologisch nachhaltige soziale
marktwirtschaft aber damit den zielen
bitte die soziale marktwirtschaft nicht
kaputtmachen wenn sie sagen
sozial-ökologischen kann ich auch sagen
lasst uns auch sozial ökologisch
nachhaltig das ist doch ein sozialer
marktwirtschaft ist sieben
fußballspieler gibt es einen ganz
starken schiedsrichter das ist der start
und dann gibt spieler die müssen sich an
bedingungen halten und eine bedingung
ist das haftungsprinzip ja walter eucken
geht noch einen schritt weiter ein ganz
großer der sozialen marktwirtschaft der
sagt externe kosten müssen übernommen
werden müssen internalisiert werden das
heißt der autobauer ja der elenas wenn
der eine idee hat und baut eine fabrik
dann muss der wenn ihr die luft
verschmutzt direkt dafür was bezahlen
das soziale marktwirtschaft das haben
wir seit jahrzehnten nicht richtig
gemacht aber es war herrlich aber eines
ist ja das muss man dann eigentlich muss
sich einen der wenigen bei ferrari
müsste das welchen spielregeln science
herzen liebe wohl nicht die regeln
ändern müssen sich leider dann auch
entschuldigen wenn sie haben ja ein 16
jahre regiert und dass sie jetzt finde
ich wunderbar klimaschutz ist ein
allmende gut also müssen wir externe
effekte internalisieren und ich finde
das wunderbar ja das soll mal wieder
zusammenrücken aber das hätten sie
machen müssen wir hätten ein co2 preis
europaweit durch treiben sollen mit
allem was wir haben und das war weder
angela merkel noch anderen cdu
politikern offenbar so wichtig dass wir
jetzt diesen mischmasch an dem
verschwinden da muss ich hin zu stellen
aber das
haben sie dann ja ja sag ich dir sage
nicht ich weiß nicht nur wie von do&co
laufen möglichst weltweit ich muss dem
thema auch mal was sagen und zwar es ist
ja eigentlich mein revier reden und
haben über die große industriehalle aber
letztendlich ist es doch der mittelstand
der eigentlich die meisten steuern
bezahlt und unsere deutschland aufrecht
erhält und gerade der mittelstand hatte
schwierig mit der ökologie weil das was
ökologisch
machbar ist ist einfach auch sehr teuer
schon alleine die genehmigungsverfahren
wenn man irgendetwas machen will muss
man da sein siegel hat und dann dieses
siegel das kostet dann auch wieder geld
also ökologisch zu sein für einen
kleinen betrieb das ist wirklich
schwierig und da gibt es wenig
unterstützung vom staat also viel zu
wenig das ist das was ich immer wieder
höre und auch selber erlebt habe und da
sollte man doch schon mal ansetzen dass
man wirklich unseren mittelstand
unterstützt und sagt hier
steuersenkungen du und oder wenn die
ökologisch etwas machen willst dann hast
du hier in deiner deine unterstützung
und es geht ihm schon darüber dass man
ihm die betriebe dass man die gebäude
das man die in ökologisch saniert dass
die arbeitsmöglichkeiten in der richtung
dass das gefördert wird
auch die angestellten alles alles
mögliche ist schon alleine die
herstellung von lebensmitteln denn wenn
das schon mal zu
sagen wir aber am ende doch in diesem
staat in diesem grünen bevormundung
start der punkt ist ja am ende es muss
ein preis geht man kann ganz ganz viel
über den preisregen und wenn man sagt
externe effekt ist ja genau das richtige
stichwort das was du lieber unternehmer
treibst das ist relativ und dreckiges
geschäft deswegen muss das was du
ausstößt an co2 stärker besteuert werden
und wird deswegen teurer das wird ihnen
automatisch dazu zwingen zu müssen der
reinen lehre dass er ein seine
produktion umstellen ja aber wenn er sie
und stellt dann muss es immer auch
gefordert werden aber und nicht so muss
das gefördert werden das muss gefördert
werden weil es sagen warum es sinn sie
ein unternehmer der viel ausstößt warum
müssen sie dem was zahlen es ist ja gar
nicht immer so dass die sehr sehr viel
ausstoßen wenn ich zum beispiel an die
lebensmittelindustrie denke an öko
bauern und so viele öko bauern die
machen schon alles ökologisch aber um
ein öko siegel zu bekommen ist das ist
so viel strenger und dieses siegel ist
so teuer und
aber geht es nicht auch generell die
sehnsucht die rückkehr des starken
staates also ich habe das gefühl vor
allem sein promoter kronen wie ein
brandbeschleuniger gewirkt für mich hat
kommunen die absolute staatsgläubigkeit
sehr sehr viele deutsche bürger auch
gezeigt und meine frage ist ob nicht der
starke start
kann ja sein aber es muss ja nicht das
sein muss in kritisch sein und ich fand
das beispiel auch so toll noch mal zu
sagen die firmen die sache wir wollen
nachhaltig produzieren der
grimme millionäre die sagen wir müssen
stärker besteuert werden jüngst wieder
mal nur leute es ist ja heiter
werden das
ist nicht nur der der sich schon im
rollstuhl dieser vergleich es geht doch
nicht darum dass erstmal den unternehmen
vor geben will was sie produzieren
sollen oder wie sie arbeiten soll ich
sage co2 zertifikatehandel ist bereits
eine politische lenkungswirkung das ist
eine art förderung nämlich einer zukunft
in der wir möglichst gesund miteinander
leben wollen und die die wirtschaft will
das dii will aber planungssicherheit die
will ein ganz klares effizientes system
haben um diese nachhaltige wirtschaft
erreichen zu können und das ist dann
trotzdem eine politische lenkungswirkung
also ja gerade eine art dass eine andere
lenkungswirkung nicht habe ich rede über
effiziente maria deswegen der
mittelstand um sie zu korrigieren von
gilt der mittel schon hat keine angst
vor ökologie der mittelstand hat angst
vor bürokratie das ist aber der umbau
den robert habeck vorhat der beschränkt
sich nicht auf den lenkungswirkung durch
den co2 preis das ist ja der trugschluss
wir haben es auch im wahlkampf erlebt da
hieß es wir machen co2 preis und dann
sollten trotzdem inlandsflüge verboten
werden oder noch mal extra preis
bekommen also entweder ich machen co2
preis und dann geht dieser co2 preis für
kerosin beispielsweise inlandsflug
auslands flugstrecke kurzstrecke ist
dann egal dann muss ich das der
verbraucher selbst aussuchen da muss
nicht noch mal die politik kommen die
geben würde ich dann auch teurer werden
wenn man nicht macht richtig genau so
ist es aber der muss edition am höchsten
nicht genau sie aber dann kommt die
grünen trotzdem noch mal wieder auch in
form von haben und sagen aber im inland
darf nicht mehr geflogen werden das
passt nicht dass sie abgerissen
dem programm aber das steckt hinter
einer sozial ökologischen
marktwirtschaft da steckt mehr dahinter
als einfach nur co2 preis denn den man
lieber michael brücker den gibt schon
länger den co2 aber der ist viel zu
niedrig oder ist nicht global und ist
nicht europa wir
wollen jetzt noch einmal
heran sie haben das letzte wort dürfen
sie zu dem thema haben weil sie es
gerade nicht zum ball zu kommen sind
ergänzt ende ist die akzeptanz
entscheidend wenn die bürgerinnen und
bürger sehen dass das was wir hier
klimapolitisch machen etwas bringt das
entweder die welt uns nach macht ja oder
es bringt hier in deutschland so viel
dass wir die dinger fakt kaufen
umwelttechnologien dann packen wir das
wenn aber die welt sieht wie zb in
gütersloh da werden luftballons verboten
mit helium also am letzten schultag
darfst du städtischen kindergarten nicht
mehr diesen luftballon in die luft gehen
lassen umwelt klima gründe und so also
ich kann mir keinen präsidenten auf
diesem globus vorstellen der das
nachmacht wir haben ja so wie ein code
mit in der schule die so jung noch vor
jahren aufhören zu sprechen aber wissen
ich denke wenn ich solche maßnahmen
mache ja
dann wenn das keiner nachmacht im 21
wundern wenn die energiewende und die
klimawende nicht auf akzeptanz stößt es
war ein gutes schlusswort wir empfehlen
jetzt dementsprechend die ein zu arten
und weiter zu benutzen wie viel um
luftballons wie aber ist doch ein ganz
tolles thema für sie und zwar volle zu
sehen uns auch was mitgebracht ja es ist
natürlich so dass es eine große
politikverdrossenheit gibt auch gerade
was die wahlen angeht ich habe jetzt
auch erlebt in oberkrämer nicht mal 50
prozent der menschen wollten ihren
bürgermeister wählen das hat sie einfach
nicht interessiert und das liegt
natürlich auch daran dass einfach die
politik politiker selbst die
bürgermeister oftmals den hierzu ihren
bürgern verloren haben es werden dinge
entschieden und die information darüber
was eigentlich
entschieden wird die ist nicht
transparent genug es ist so ein
lippenbekenntnis dass man sagt ja auf
der internetseite blablabla dort das
steht ja alles aber welch ein normaler
mensch
empfindet das dann also ich nicht ich
muss immer meine freundin fragen sag mal
auf welcher seite ich finde ich bin das
was jetzt geplant ist und wenn ich dann
gefunden habe dann lädt sich einen
beamten deutsch das ich nicht verstehe
mich sagt er ist es jetzt gut oder so
schlecht was meinen die dann eigentlich
damit also dieser ganze
informationsfluss der ist schon mal sehr
schlecht und dann werden dinge entschied
und dann stehen sie im amtsblatt und da
sagt man jetzt steht ja alles im
amtsblatt wenn es dann da erstmal steht
kann der bürger nichts mehr dagegen tun
und wenn er was du wenn er sich aufrafft
umkämpft und sagt ich möchte das
verändern und eine petition ins leben
rufen dann sagen doch die meisten
interessiert uns nicht und und das dann
bürger um mal sagen die politik
interessiert mich durch das machen die
da oben ich habe hier keinen einfluss
ist auch egal welche partei die klingeln
da etwas vor sich hin also ich bleibt zu
hause und gehen nicht gehen und setzte
mich nicht ein das ist doch dann
selbstverständlich oder wenn sie
parteien wählen
aus protest
und das ist natürlich dann auch die
große gefahr dass sie dann parteien
wählen die eigentlich nicht demokratisch
so
große zustimmung ja die frage ist was
kann man machen könnte volksabstimmung
machen da wäre ich auf der kommunalen
ebene bei bestimmt ja und nein fragen
offen ihr komplizierter es wird
schwierig wir sehen es auch beim rexit
wo viele sagen ich hätte doch anders
entschieden
ich glaube am ende braucht es zwei dinge
um die politikverdrossenheit
kleinzukriegen erster politiker brauchen
eine klare haltung eine klare meinung
auch parteien wenn du den unterschied
zwischen den parteien nicht mehr erkennt
gibt es protest und dann reduzieren
protestparteien ja auch wie die afd das
zweite ist wirklich heraus also das ist
zwar nett hier in berlin-mitte ja ich
bin jetzt hier auch über die
friedrichstraße bekommen ist alles gut
und schön aber das ist wirklich nicht
die realität das wissen wir alle das ist
einfach so und ich mache es halt so habe
ich von wolfgang bosbach gelernt ich
rufe jeden bürger in meinem wahlkreis an
der sich meldet oder schreibe ihm eine e
mail macht ich persönlich nicht
irgendwie dass der mitarbeiter schreibt
viele grüße von der lindemann und stimme
gar nicht sondern ich mache ist nur in
meinem wahlkreis also jetzt nicht bitte
ganz deutschland
jede wahlkreis an einem online spiel
also immer den auf den abriss da aber
das funktioniert dann haben die leute
nicht nur das gefühl man kümmert sich
man weiß worum es geht und das finde ich
dass das mindeste was man von
abgeordneten jahre teilen immer sagt
natürlich jetzt nur die halbe wahrheit
denn mit der basis haben ja die cdu
politiker so ihre eigenen probleme die
basisbefragung jetzt die ja ihren
wunschkandidaten vor gewartet er soll
nur einmal gemacht werden natürlich
ausnahmsweise und nie wieder also und
ich finde übrigens auch mit gutem mit
guten grund ich bin ein großer anhänger
der repräsentativen demokratie darf wir
haben die aus gutem grund eingeführt und
ich finde diese ganzen debatten rund um
die bürgerbeteiligung aus meiner sicht
dass nebenkriegsschauplätze wenn wir
eine wirksame nachvollziehbare
transparente politik machen würden die
nach einer guten offenen debatte endet
auch zur entscheidung führt die kleine
kommuniziert werden brauchen wir nicht
alle zwei wochen unsere bürger anrufen
und fragen ob sie das oder das thema
haben wollen es ist natürlich auch
wirklich einen unterschied ob man dass
die bundespolitik nimmt oder auch eine
große stadt wie berlin oder ob man jetzt
im kommunalen bereich unterwegs ist da
finde ich sollte sollten die bürger auf
die straße auch schon sehr viele
maßnahmen der bürgerbeteiligung finde
ich auf ja da gibt es viele maßnahmen
das sind oft nur lippenbekenntnisse das
habe ich doch ganz oft erlebt dann sagen
wir ja und hier ist jetzt die
bürgersprechstunde du hast drei minuten
zeit deine anmerkung zu machen und dann
wird der bock ich habe ja was
aufgeschrieben und dann tragen die das
vor mit dem mut eines ganz normalen
menschen und danach drei millionen pro
jahr vorbei es nie haben wir doch alles
gemacht und da haben wir ja informiert
und da haben wir ja das läuft ja alles
und dann wird man mit einer
freundlichen arroganz abgefertigt das
habe ich so rossi die man eher sagen
jetzt das grundsatzprogramm für die cdu
schreibe mich würde interessieren was
steht da drin an basis beteiligung was
steht dann wirklich am ende drin für die
bürgerbeteiligung wenn es nach ihnen
ginge herr lehmann nein bei den großen
komplizierten sachen gesehen dass beim
exit bei einer steuerreform bei einer
gesundheitsreform nein aber die
beteiligung auch der basis beim
grundsatzprogramm müssen wir viel mehr
machen bräuchten zum beispiel ich sage
mal die haben ja solche ressourcen wenn
wir jetzt zum beispiel sagen jeder
müsste man ein paar angaben machen
natürlich freiwillig aber wir haben
jetzt ein problem in der schule
digitalisierung friedrich merz würde
sagen ich möchte gerne mal mit den 137
schulleitern reden die ihnen die ein
parteibuch haben dann muss das doch
möglich sein und damit er auch meine
meinung bekommen von kultusminister
kommen sie von den leuten ja aber sie
müssen nicht einmal dieses ist geht
nicht weil du bist ja ich mal in einem
land leben wo man eine idee hat
loslaufen und die man umsetzen ich sage
ja nicht gibt es nicht das ist um einen
wahlspruch gewesen und ich bin dazu
politik eigentlich bekommen durch den
flughafen tegel eine petition über 200
usd durch christian lindner er kam
später
nein also die fdp die hatte mich gefragt
ob ich nicht bei der petition mitmachen
will zum erhalt des flughafen tegels
weit über 200.000 unterschriften
gesammelt und wenn man einmal eine
petition als normaler bürger gestartet
hat dann weiß man was das für eine
arbeit macht auf fremde leute zuzugehen
könntest du hier unterschreiben und so
viele songs doch ab und lass mich in
ruhe wenn nicht alle sind freundlich und
viele sagen nein unterschrift setzte ich
nicht runter ich bin ja dafür aber ich
unterschreibe hier nichts dann kriegt
man trotzdem so viele stimmen zusammen
und kein interessiert das ist doch schon
mal traurig es ist ja schon im vorfeld
traurig gewesen dass keiner gefragt
wurde ja wir machen da das überhaupt
hier mit den mit dem flughafen in
schönefeld da wurde schon im vorfeld
geklingelt ja okay wir schließen den es
wurde auch der linie auch nicht gefragt
wie machen wir das eigentlich wenn die
deutsche wohn enteignet ist ja wo kommt
das geld eigentlich hier die 30
milliarden oder 35 wurde auch nicht es
wurde nie gefragt der bürger wurde nicht
mit einbezogen und wenn sie sich dann
beschweren dann auch g
internet so sehe ich das im großen und
so sehe ich so auch in kleinen und ich
es gilt bestimmt nicht für alle
bürgermeister es gibt bestimmt auch
welche die sind sehr nett mit ihren
bürgern aber zu oft erlebe ich es
einfach dass die bürgermeister die
verantwortung an die verwaltung
abschieben ja der ist für den bau
zuständig und jetzt dies da für soziales
und dies für familie und dann
verschieben die das und kümmern sich
nicht selber wirklich persönlich um den
bürger und sein okay eure anliegen setze
ich hier bei meiner verwaltung durch ich
würde mal sagen die bürger sind
natürlich ein bisschen schizophren wir
wollen ja die daten nicht abgeben und
wir wollen uns nicht wirklich beteiligen
und wir kümmern uns nicht um die großen
politischen fragen und dann kommt
plötzlich eine pandemie und wir
unterschreiben überall brav unsere
unseren namen unserer daten geben die ab
damit findet kaffee trinken können also
ich würde mir wünschen dass eine lehre
nach der panne mich auf jeden fall ist
wir müssen uns bürger wenn wir
mitgestalten wollen auch bereits an mehr
von uns wirklich preiszugeben ich finde
das ist da müssen wir durch sonst gibt
es keine elektronische patientenakte
also keine wirksame wir sehen es ja
jetzt wieder herzen und das wäre für
mich auch eine form der
bürgerbeteiligung dass es auch eine
bringschuld der bürger ist dinge
natürlich preiszugeben wenn wir eine
bessere organisation des staates haben
wollen müssen wir das machen ob das
jetzt das parteibüro als lehrer ist bei
mir waren sie ohnehin alle sicherlich
nicht cdu insofern die frage haben wir
einen schon geklärt das weiß ich jetzt
nicht ob man das machen sollte aber wir
müssen auf jeden fall denn ehrlich mit
und sein und dann dinge auch preisgeben
wenn wir besser organisieren also da
haben organisationen haben und ich weiß
zum beispiel nicht wie robert habe jetzt
dieses klima geld auszahlen will über
welches format läuft das auch nicht klar
es gibt keine id für jeden bürger aber
kann mir ist leider nicht mehr die
bürger gehört das schlusswort heute
abend jetzt großen spaß gemacht endlich
sind wir zurück und morgen abend gibt es
dann auch schon direkt eine neue folge
paul ronzheimer wird da sein und sahra
wagenknecht es wird sehr spannend werden
und bestimmt genauso leidenschaftlich
wie heute abend und wir wünschen ihnen
jetzt zu hause noch einen schönen abend
diskutieren sie doch ihren freunden und
ihrer familie denn die demokratie
braucht definitiv leidenschaftliche
diskussionen
[Musik]